people haven't just died during the
pandemic because of the virus they died
of other causes too and that's made
clear by the most complete analysis so
far of excess deaths according to the
office for national statistics almost
134 000 more people died up to the end
of last year in england and wales than
expected from the five year average much
of that rise has been in men up more
than 17 in women the rise was just under
11
now if you look at the timeline you can
see how excess deaths have fluctuated
above and below the expected level which
we've zeroed on the chart
you can see big peaks in april 2020 in
the first wave and in january 2021
during the second but strip out deaths
due to coronavirus and the results get
more intriguing so there was still a
peak in non-covered excess deaths in
that first wave here in light blue
probably because of a lack of testing
meant some deaths really caused by the
virus were attributed to other medical
conditions on the death certificates but
excess death from other causes dipped
sharply during the second wave probably
partly because lockdown meant flu and
other respiratory diseases were at low
levels they then rose again and remained
high for the whole of the second half of
last year probably because those
respiratory diseases got going again in
the autumn and lots of people were
vulnerable
overall looking at the whole period
there were almost seven and a half
thousand fewer non-coveted death than
you would expect
what really stands out is the difficulty
people with underlying health conditions
had in accessing health care for example
deaths from dementia and alzheimer's
rose 71 at home but they fell 31
in hospitals and deaths from colon
cancer rose almost 37 at home but they
fell almost 19 in hospices when you look
at a map there's lots of variation in
excess deaths but no obvious geographic
pattern and no clear link with
deprivation but there were slightly more
than expected in rural areas and
slightly fewer in towns and cities so
how does all this compare with other
countries well earlier this month a
study in the lancet medical journal
looked at excess deaths around the world
and they found the uk ranked ninth in
western europe with a rate of just under
127 per 100 000 people rates were higher
in italy and spain but slightly lower in
germany and france the pandemic has
taken a dreadful toll on most countries
and understanding the statistics will be
key to learning the lessons